for me it felt like she created this
invitation for black woman
and this healing realm for black women
to come into when i think about how she
really helped
excavate um the work of zora neil
hurston
when i think about her she just came to
me literally i was just thinking i'm
sorry to interrupt but yeah no
interruption
[Music]
garrett oh
so wonderful to see you again especially
in this moment yeah well thank you i'm
just like i'm so
i'm so impressed by your film i feel
like i've
had the pleasure of seeing it a few
times in person before
the pandemic it's such a beautiful film
and you're such a beautiful person and
filmmaker and so i and you're in a
beautiful setting right now with
with greenery and for you garrett
normally in this chair with the white
wall i'm in editing this week so i've
just been like
a blob on a couch and was excited to get
together get myself together for you
yeah well thank you thanks for being
here with you jared i'm so
excited for you congratulations what a
gorgeous film
um something that i love that both of
our films are in conversation with is
the idea of an archive
yours being a physical tangible archive
mind being
one that's more of a spiritual ethereal
archive and so
i would love to know from you how you
engaged with
an archive as a child wow that's a
really good question
my parents were really independently
independent
people um and i grew up with my mom
you know for the most part i didn't
really develop a relationship with my
dad until i got a little bit older
um and so my grandmother really was the
one to
have the photos you know um
and she really is as i think many of our
families the grandmother usually is the
archivist of the
family i don't know about for you and so
there was a lot of
um you know actually perfectly curated
books you know with the plastic on the
with the self-adhesive
my dad yes
yeah so i mean i was lucky enough to be
able to
to access that and i think as i've
gotten older you know my mom
certainly there's a lot of physical
photographs that we have that are in
boxes that haven't been organized and
i'm glad you asked me about this because
i one of my
my things i need to do that i know i
need to do is
organize this archive for my mom and put
it into
those little laminated binders and just
take them out of the boxes and put them
in a place that can be seen it's like a
dream of mine you know
but i don't think i was really actively
involved it was sort of like just
something i kind of took for granted to
a certain extent like you see it people
sit you down they want to talk to you
about it but i wasn't really
thinking about it critically i think
that's so interesting because
now as an adult i'm thinking about it
critically and
i wish i could go back in time and as a
child really hold on to those moments
and it's so interesting to hear you
speak about your grandmother
and the record she kept because my dad
has a
binders that he made for myself my
brother and my mom and within the
binders are
pamphlets or little brochures our birth
certificates anything we've done
from existence of us being born to
art concerts theater performances
and i didn't realize why my dad did that
until years later and also what i love
so much about
time garrett is that we're allowed into
this private space
and i think that's something i long for
to revisit my
archive and enter a private space with
it with these memories
a lot of my memories were really
abruptly like they abruptly shifted for
me when i was 15 my dad passed away so
a lot of my memories feel like dreams
and a part of me i've been thinking
about
what's going to happen the first time i
watch a vhs tape that shows me and my
dad together just because
you know i'm 33 now what is that moment
going to be like how will i engage with
that for so long i've lived on just the
memories and the stories
um and so as a child
i i was so present in the moment that i
wasn't thinking about
what will remain when that time is
is gone and is over yeah i mean i could
see how that also filters into
into process right and into when i think
about your film
when we're talking about the absence of
things you know filling
filling spaces that you know you know
that there's uh
there is something there but there's um
there's a different kind of evidence for
it it's evidence that is
based on intuition based on emotional
knowledge maybe it's not physical
you know or or validated by fact in the
same kind of way
and you you've talked about um cydia
hartman and
alice walker as being influences and i'm
wondering for you
how you use audio in this film because
this idea
you know she's looking at these images
and she's using text
right to sort of fill in the absence of
things and when we're making films
we're sometimes doing it the other way
around or maybe not so i'm curious for
you
did the dialogue come first did the
images come first in your mind's eye
you know how did those things coalesce
and come together and maybe
you know how were you pulling from sidea
and and from
from miss walker's work too uh
with the archive before i ever conducted
an
interview with tai and shanice i
remember
filming for a couple of days with
several of the young girls because i
wanted
to enter this world that i was thinking
about
i wanted to let that world i want it to
be conjured into that world and fill it
and so i let myself understand what i
wanted my visual language to be at the
beginning
and then after the interviews i allowed
their voices and their memories to
inform the rest of the work
so i think a part of me is always
wanting
to insert myself into these archives as
well even when they aren't mine but
finding personal ways that
i'm leaving a bit of my own evidence
within
this existence because there are a
couple of moments in
a love song for latasha where i am using
a part of my body as
as a person within the film and i even
am noticing myself do that with newer
projects of me needing to insert myself
within the archive because
i have such a fear of erasure i started
to discover
um understanding how that's happened to
so many black women creatives
for sadia she really gave me the
critical
thinking that i needed to interrogate
this idea
she gave me the language i needed
critical fabulation which i know
you're very familiar with and you know
have been in conversation with her about
this
and and i'm always looking for that
balance of art
and critical theory to inform my work
that i need the language i need the
ideology
to give to name what i feel to name the
intuition to name my spirit um
and then alice walker she built these
worlds that i understood existed
but that that it wasn't a physical place
and for me it felt like she created this
invitation for black woman
and this healing realm for black women
to come into when i think about how she
really helped
excavate um the work of zora neil
hurston
when i think about her she just came to
me literally i was just thinking of i'm
sorry
to interrupt but yeah no interruption
when i when i graduated from grad school
i got a zord no herston tattoo because
she helped guide me through
that last year zore's always thinking
about the horizon
always wanting to go towards the horizon
and also if we want to talk about zora
her autobiography is such an inspiration
to me because
she decides what she wants to place
within the archive and what she wants to
keep out
and you see her curating her own memory
and existence and adding folkloric into
that
and something i'm very inspired by and
so alice walker
taught me that as a black woman i can
call on these
these ancestors and be in collaboration
with them you know what i love about
alice is when she went on this journey
to rediscover zora
to read births or she would tell people
that was my aunt because she knew
having that connection would make people
open up and so thinking about well even
if we're not blood related
we're all the same lineage of artists
we're all we know
the more that i do it is the
continuation of all the black women
before me who weren't able to do it and
what i do
others after me will continue to do that
work so understanding that we're all in
conversation
in a spiritual essence and so uh those
two brilliant women were such
inspirations for me within that process
yes
i i'm so curious with your journey
because what i love is thinking about
your short film alone it was originally
shortlisted for the academy awards
and now time is finally receiving you
know
yes take up this space you deserve to be
here
and i'm curious i think for both of us
having a very distinctive voice
and ex and using experimental methods
within documentary what was that journey
like for you
to really feel confident in your voice
to feel confident in your style doing
something that's
not conventional it's funny because this
sounds disparaging
and i don't mean it to be at all because
i'm happy with myself and who i am right
but um when people ask me this question
about doing something that feels
different i kind of i'm just thinking
well this is the only way i know how
like i'm doing
the best i can do like that's that's
truly how
it it sort of metabolizes in my body and
in my mind like i
i went to film school i made some i made
some incredible friends
um had mentors that's where i met billy
woodbury it's where i learned about you
know
a whole movement of filmmaking that
wasn't taught to me in any other context
really
uh people who i'm who i still really
lean on you know
and who are a huge part of my community
when i was there but
you know there were moments within that
program
you know certain rules you learn about
the tradition of filmmaking and that was
also it's actually why i went to film
school not because i
actually wanted to make hollywood films
or that i thought i was even capable of
doing it but because
i studied religion as an undergraduate i
knew i was always interested in film i'd
been making little
films since i was in high school but i
needed to have formal training and i
needed to get my hands on a camera
and i needed to be able to work with
people who i wasn't going to pay
to deal with me and vice versa so
film school was my my gave me the
ability to do that and
um but then there was you know in my
pursuit of trying to understand
understand the tradition i think myself
along with many others
you get to a point in any program any
kind of graduate program i think where
you get really frustrated and
self-defeating because
you're not doing it right you know
you're like why am i not and especially
when you're younger you're so focused on
your worth is about how well you can
master something how well you
can essentially fit into the box yes how
how well can you draw into the lines you
know what i mean
and that becomes some kind of foray or
some kind of
indication of if you're worthy of it or
not you know
and that's when your confidence starts
to get bad and you start to hate the
program
and then you know things happen and this
happens to all of us i think i
understand this so deeply
yes yeah i feel really grateful because
in that moment
of feeling defeated in that moment of
not being able to understand
you know especially with my dyslexia
like crossing the line and like doing
all those like things it was
like i can't do this i'm not doing it
like it was just so hard you know
in that moment it really i tried to use
it as a as a prompt
to further understand myself to that it
was actually
it was a gift because it was something
from which i could bounce off of to
further see myself
and to further articulate what i can do
and what i want to do and what i'm
interested in doing
and i think it was actually similar to
you know when i was younger when i was
in high school
you know a lot of this is a very
gendered experience and i'm hoping that
um
i think it's changed even since since
you and i were younger but
uh you know then like a lot of the guys
were really good at coming together and
working together and helping each other
out
absolutely you know yeah and i feel like
myself and a lot of my other girlfriends
were more independent and so
i really had to learn how to if i was
going to be interested in making films
i needed to learn how to do them by
myself without a crew or a team
um and that forced me into
a certain methodology that was really
reliant on what i could do on my own
that was really reliant on this idea
of questions as questions being equally
as important as answers in some ways
and it's what helped me ultimately to as
you mentioned
find the confidence to be curious right
so those two things kind of conflated
is is how i developed
myself you know um and it wasn't it i
was i was never invested in trying to go
against the grain and trying to do
something that was different
i'm not actually interested in like
rebellion in that way
um it truly is just uh
who i am it's the only way i know how to
do it you know then you get to a certain
point where you
start to say okay i feel like i've
exercised this muscle what what other
muscles can i exercise and that's where
i think for me it gets really exciting
because that's where the collaborative
process
needs to open up that's where you start
to bring in more people and you work
with
brilliant human beings who who are
bringing so much and helping you to
elevate the work
in a way that you yourself you know
could never do by your
you know on your own that's what
filmmaking is it's collaborative you
know
that's really beautiful garrett and it
resonates so deeply
when i was in undergrad i found myself
trying to emulate
everyone i saw around me i understood
how you make a great photo within
photojournalism my undergraduate degree
was in photojournalism
and i i felt like i couldn't breathe i
felt like i was losing who i was
and i had to take a time of unlearning
everything removing myself from
all the education i had i took a break
within my
during my second year of grad school
because i wanted to fail
i wanted to mess up i wanted to return
to my own personal roots to really
allow myself to rebirth who i was
supposed to be
not thinking about anyone else what
success is supposed to look like
um what i've been taught but also i
really had been trained to do
everything you learn how to do the audio
you learn how to
do the cinematography the editing and i
do think that was something that was
really helpful in me
discovering my voice by understanding
the importance of each element
i understood what i liked um and so
now it's so fun for me to collaborate
because i'm like oh now i understand who
i
am and i want to accept and embrace who
you are and see how we can put these
these two worlds together um it's
it's so true though that men have always
looked out for one another within school
within the industry
and it's really been inspiring to me and
exciting for me to see
you know women taking over women women
taking their their rightful place within
the world of cinema it's long overdue
and
it really is i remember watching your
film garrett
wanting to see what it did because i was
rooting for it i was like this needs to
get to this place we need to make sure
we have
black women storytellers at this level
not saying this level is the reason
we're good not saying this
acknowledgement
um makes us better but understanding
what it means in the sense of how we
get to continue doing the work
understanding how it provides resources
understanding how it allows us to
continue
telling these stories yes yes so well
said you know speaking of women i think
both of us have an affinity
um for uh women's voices for women's
stories
and i'm curious because i'm always asked
about this and i'm curious for you
is that intentional or is that intuitive
especially when we talk about love song
philatasha like what
what brought you to that story and
was it connected to something that is
that is broader
um that is even bigger that is connected
to sort of overall intention
with your work it's intuitive and i
think the way you answered about
you know this is just who i am when when
you create your work
i don't know how to do anything else
this is what i know
this is what i love these are the
stories i care about
and and i'm not ashamed to be dedicated
to that i don't
want to ever act like i'm someone that
wants to tell
all of these stories like no i love
telling stories about women i love
telling stories about
black girls black women you know queer
folks
and for me a love song for latasha
it felt very close to home because i am
a native of los angeles i was a young
girl during the riots
and i always associated it with rodney
king so for me
to witness this erasure happen in
history where latasha's name
always existed within that trauma i
really wanted to
to disrupt that archive and to provide
healing for black women
healing for the community and
i wanted us to have a tangible record i
wanted it this to be a spiritual archive
for people to know how important her
existence was
how important her memory is and what it
looks like for us to continue moving
forward in
our um dismantling of anti-blackness
and our dismantling of the erasure of
black woman
and in acknowledging the adultification
that happens to young black girls
but i didn't approach this film thinking
i
was being political i don't think that's
ever my thought i'm never trying to be
political
but i think i can't remove the political
aspect from the story
for me it was always this is a story
that needs to exist i
want to be a part of this journey with
tai and shanice
to rebirth these memories to give them a
place to live
tangibly and as i mentioned when my dad
passed when i was a young girl i was the
same age as latasha so i've always had
a desire to tell a story about a 15 year
old black girl and i just didn't
understand this is the moment
that it would come together this is the
moment that it would happen and
something i do want to mention garrett
that i think is so interesting
about both of our films this is
understanding of time
you know thinking about your title but
also
the whole concept of serving time
of moving through time of time being
non-linear
we both are dealing with stories that
were deeply deeply ingrained in the past
but we're watching this rebirth we're
watching a moment happen where that
archive gets to finally live
and it makes me think about um a quote
that my mentor opiemio leukemia shared
with me the future informs the past
and so watching your film i was like i
know
i i doubt they ever thought when we were
creating this archive that one day we
would meet garrett bradley
and she would present this to the world
and it would make sense why
sybil was creating these these videos
why this record was so important
and so i'd love you for you to just
speak about your own personal
exploration of time
what it meant to experience time with
the family
and just how you all navigated your own
understandings of time
first and foremost like i came to
to meet fox and to meet robert and to
meet the whole family on the premise of
um the absence of understanding and
images
around the effects of incarceration
right the
effects of and speaking of ava when we
think about her film 13th right which is
um a critical content you know
um that helps people understand the
connection between slavery in our
country
and the prison industrial complex right
and i feel like time stands on the
shoulders of a film like 13th and it
show it's the other half of the circle
in the sense that it is speaking to now
understanding that on the on the the
micro level
understanding it on the human the human
level
the emotional level you know first and
foremost
that is kind of like where i came in and
it was a lot of conversations with them
in the beginning with the family around
why do we want to make this film you
know
and and and fox and rob were very clear
with me and saying you know our story is
the story of 2.3 million american
families
and we feel that our story can offer
hope and so i felt like
you know my job was to try to distill
and understand what hope
meant for them and what it looked like
in their daily life in ritual and
routine
um how was that articulated in
actionable terms in cinematic terms
and that inevitably encompassed the
concept of time
right the concept of of all tenses of
time
the the construct of time time as a
weapon right
time is something that is also um both
very concrete and abstract
all at once and and the thing that that
ultimately i think i've taken away from
this and you know to kind of answer your
question like
those hope ended up looking like three
things it ended up looking like love
you know it ended up looking like unity
the ability for them to stay together
over the course of
two decades without being physically
connected to one another which is
something that families
who are physically under the same
household sometimes don't have
you know um and it was being an
individual none of them is
are are defined by the system in any
kind of way and
the beauty of that is love and unity
and and individualism are not bound by
time
they're not bound by linearity or or
chronology they surpass
all of those things and so that allowed
us you know particularly with the
archive which my not knowing that the
archive existed until our last day of
filming
and having to completely rethink not the
intention
but the structure of the film yes i
still had anchoring points that were
rooted
into something that was transparent and
agreed upon collectively with the family
you know which was hope which was the
the three articulations of hope for them
and so that's a really big answer but at
the end of the day it's a love
it's it's about two people and and their
children and
and how they manage to get through two
decades of hell
in these very mundane and almost
quotidian ways that
anybody can use anyone can can
can uh can fight with and that people
actively are
you know 2.3 million americans actively
are if not double triple quadruple that
number if you take into account the
family
it is truly is a love story yes it's a
love story and i think your film
also is is truly it's truly a testament
of love to latasha to black girls to
to the potential of what america can be
and should be uh
to the form of cinema so i just want to
say thank you
so much for like speaking with me today
and i and i
will be together in person and we'll be
celebrating
not only each other and our films but
everyone who helped make them come to
fruition and
uh thank you for your work and i just
can't wait to to see everything you're
going to be doing and no pressure no
rush but i'm ready
thank you for saying no rush that's the
sweetest thing someone could say garrett
this is such a joy such an honor
i am truly a deep fan of your work i
love
watching you create i am going to
continue being a fan of your work and
a friend to walk through this industry
with you
but thank you so much for spending this
time with me 30 minutes is not enough
time
you